des inondations monstres
des tempêtes violentes
et des quantités de neige dignes de
décors hollywoodiens certains endroits
en ont reçu jusqu'à 18 mètres des
événements météorologiques qui ont fait
au moins 20 morts
plus d'une douzaine de rivières
atmosphériques se sont abattus en
Californie en quelques mois une rivière
atmosphérique est une masse de vapeur
d'eau qui provient des tropiques et qui
amènent d'abondantes précipitations
une rivière qui se déverse c'est
l'équivalent de 25 fois à la quantité
d'eau du fleuve Mississippi affirme le
météorologue un contraste avec les
années de sécheresse extrême que l'État
viennent traverser et on s'attend à une
augmentation du ruissellement de l'eau
de montagne ce qui a forcé certaines
municipalités à ouvrir les écluses et
des réservoirs pour empêcher des
inondations supplémentaires
et nous avons atteint des records de
précipitation et la saison n'est pas
terminée
les rivières atmosphériques sont
pourtant des phénomènes bien connus en
Californie en fait elle fournissent de
40 à 60% des réserves d'eau de l'État
si on une quantité habituelle ça va si
on en reçoit trop c'est inonde ici on en
reçoit moins il y a des sécheresses
notre état se définit par la quantité de
précipitation que nous recevons lance
Rob kormark les agriculteurs
californiens et produisent la moitié de
tous les fruits et légumes des
États-Unis ceux qui ne sont pas inondés
cette année vont profiter de ce surplus
d'eau si les trop tôt pour faire un lien
direct entre les événements des derniers
mois et les changements climatiques on
peut affirmer que les réchauffements de
la planète ne fera qu'empirer les choses
que la probabilité d'avoir ce type
d'événement augmente mais ça fait partie
de la signature des événements qu'on
anticipe pour les changements
climatiques entre sécheresse et tempête
violente l'État est au bord du gouffre
ici Elisa serrer Radio-Canada Montréal